GOOD AFTERNOON --
I'M CALLING TO ORDER THE HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I WILL START IS
SUBCOMMITTEE --
THE SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL
MOMENT APPEARS WE HAVE A FORUM --
WE HAVE TWELVE MEASURES ON FILE
TODAY FIVE ON CONSENT THE
CONSENT ITEMS ARE AS FOLLOWS
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTIES
FOURTEEN OF SIX BY MR GLORIA
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SPD A NINETY
TWO BY MISTER PAN ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. B. LEVEL FOR THE MISTER
ROTH.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SP TWELVE WITH
THREE OF US BATES ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SP.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY CENTER
FULLER AT LEAST SEVEN BILLS TO
BE HEARD WILL TAKE THE TESTIMONY
FROM TWO WITNESSES SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ONLY TEACH MEASURE THAT'S TO A
TWO TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH ONLY.
EACH WITNESS AGAIN WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES ALL OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ARE WELCOME TO COME
TO THE MICROPHONE AND GIVE.
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
OPPOSITE POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY.
WE MAKE IT.
I HAVE SHOULD ONLY OKAY GOOD --
A CENTER FULLER'S ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE I WAS MISTAKEN THAT IS NOT
ON CONSENT NOT ON CONSENT.
SO WITH THAT OF WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND START AGAIN AS A SUB REALLY
[inaudible]
UP WITH.
IT'S IT'S I IT'S ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE I'M A
CENTER MONNING THAT IS ON
CONSENT.
AS WELL AS THE OTHERS THAT I
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED WILL START
WITH THE OR FIRST AUTHOR WITH
HIS I HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SENATOR FULLER IS A S. B.
.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
LET ME START BY THANKING YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE FOR WORKING SO
CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE AND FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK IT TOOK TO GET
IT DONE.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT --
WE ARE REALLY HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ND TO DELETE THE TWO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND KEEP THE
EXISTING MEMBERSHIP OF THE
COMMITTEE.
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE SIX TO
REMOVE OBSTACLES AND EASE THE
WORKLOAD OF THE VOLUNTEER
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE OF
CREDENTIALS WITHIN THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING.
THE COMMITTEE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
INITIATING ALL INVESTIGATIONS
INTO ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT.
BY CREDENTIAL HOLDERS AND
RECOMMENDING DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS TO THE COMMISSION AS
WELL AS VETTING NEW CREDENTIAL
APPLICANTS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE VOLUNTEERS
WHO ME THREE DAYS EACH MONTH TO
REVIEW THE CASES.
IN AN EFFORT TO MAINTAIN A
QUORUM SP THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
WOULD ALLOW THE COMMITTEE TO
ESTABLISH AN ALTERNATE LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FILLING UNANTICIPATED VACANCIES.
THERE WOULD ALSO ENABLE THE
COMMITTEE TO ESTABLISH A LIST OF
QUALIFIED FORMER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILLING TO ACT AS
TEMPORARY SUBSTITUTES FOR
MEMBERS WHO ARE SICK OR ABSENT.
IN ORDER TO EASE RECRUITMENT S.
B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WOULD
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT THAT
FORMALLY CERTIFICATED
INDIVIDUALS BE AT LEAST FIVE
YEARS REMOVED FROM THEIR LAST
CERTIFICATED POSITION.
AND WITH ME TODAY TO ANSWER MY
QUESTIONS OR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
EXCEPT FIVE HOPING EL A VOTE FOR
ME TODAY HOPE THIS BILL.
ONIS A GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AND
PUBLIC AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING JOSHUA SPEAKS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WAS HE GOING TO TEST.
ONE A JUST TO US SAY THAT AS
SENATOR FULLER SAID I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE THANK YOU --
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SENIOR OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS ISABEL GARCIA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WE ARE HAPPY TO
WITHDRAW.
PROPOSITION WE WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF THE
DISTINGUISHED AUTHOR AND SPONSOR.
FOR WORKING WITH A STRICT DRESS
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE BALLOT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING OPPOSITION.
I ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY WILL WAIT --
FOR MOTION UNTIL SUCH TIME AS WE
HAVE ACCORDING.
TO I MEAN ONE MORE FOR COURTS
WERE NOT THERE OF AND I THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING THE BILL LIKE --
I APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
WITH US AND OTHERS --
TO TIED TO GET TO THE FINAL
PRODUCT AND I REMAIN YOU KNOW
WHAT I AS I SURELY YOU HAVE SOME
CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE PROTOCOLS ESTABLISH
ABOUT HOW THESE CASES ARE
HANDLED BY NO THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT TODAY YOU YOU
DO WANT TO GET THESE HANDLED.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
TODAY SO THANK YOU.
AND WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR DILIGENT EFFORTS DEPEND LOT
OF TIME AND AND I THINK WE'RE IN
A BETTER PLACE THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU.
SO OF MAKE A MOTION IN A IN A
BIT I WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TURN.
TO A CITY SENATOR PELL HERE I
DON'T SEE SENATOR BILL --
CENTER WHEN I DON'T SEE SENATOR
WHEN -- I
DON'T SEE SIT --
WHO ELSE?
OKAY I DON'T SIERRA BUT IF THEIR
STAFFS LISTENING IF THEY WANT
THE BILL TO GET THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE THEY BETTER GET HIM
DOWN HERE NOW
.
SO WE NEED TO HEAR WHAT SENATOR
PELL.
THE CENTER WHEN.
CENTER DE LEóN [inaudible]
EVEN [inaudible]
THEN DODD [inaudible]
THE NOUN.
HERE WE GO [inaudible]
THERE'S ONE SENATOR BELLOWS
PRESENT --
IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT S.
B. TEN NINETEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAW.
THIS IS OUR I SP TEN NINETEEN
THIS IS THE SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERSHIPS --
BILL AND I LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING ALL OVER COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IN --
THANK YOU FOR THE WORKING WITH
ME YOURSELF AND YOUR STAFF
[inaudible]
AND EVERYBODY WORKING ON THAT --
NOW I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE
THAT.
WITH OUR ALL AMENDMENTS THAT WE
DID IN THE GROUPS.
PREVIOUSLY OPPOSING THIS BILL
ANNOUNCED SUPPORT.
THIS BILL CREATES --
S. B. TWO NINETEEN CREATES
PARITY IN ALLOCATION CRISIS
INTERVENTION FRONTS.
COMMENT REFERRED TO AS TRIAGE
FUNDS.
AND BOLSTER BOLSTERS MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PARTNERSHIPS.
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND REGIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES.
NOW SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
ALLOCATES AT LEAST HALF TO
TRIAGE GRANT FUNDS FOR SERVICES
[inaudible]
TARGETED YOU.
CRATES PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
SCHOOLS.
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
OPERATING IN THE COUNTY NOT WORK
[inaudible]
NOW CURRENTLY.
A CRISIS MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING
FOR YOU CENTRIC PROGRAM.
SEEM TO OF 50% OF THE GROUNDS
PREVIOUSLY AWARDED.
NOW THE REMAINING 885% WERE
ALLOCATED ACTUALLY TO ADULTS
[inaudible]
SO --
CHILDREN DID NOT GET --
THE BULK OF THE FUNDS.
WE MUST ENSURE THE CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS ARE GIVEN
EQUAL ACCESS. TO RESOURCES THAT
ADULTS RECEIVING.
THE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS.
AND COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
OFFER STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND
EXTENDED NETWORK.
A MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
AND SERVICES THAT ARE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE.
THE THE BILL INSURERS
COLLABORATION.
WITH ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
AND THE DEPEND AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO SURE THE GRANTS OR
ADMINISTERS.
FROM BOTH PERSPECTIVES.
S. B. TWO NINETEEN HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT BY.
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE WESTERN
CENTER A LOT PROPERTY I HAVE
SOME WITNESSES ALTERNATE OVER
THERE --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE A
RECENT AUDITOR'S REPORT FOUND
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS HAVE A SERIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISORDER BUT
ONLY A FRACTION ABOUT 20%.
RECEIVE THERAPY OR COUNSELING AS
PART OF THEIR INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PROGRAM.
A LACK OF COORDINATED INTEGRATED
APPROACHES BY COUNTIES IN
SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE MOST
DEEPLY IMPACTED BY CHILDHOOD
ADVERSITY.
CONTRIBUTE TO STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS NOT BEING MET.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AS A WAY TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO NEEDED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES [inaudible]
ENERGIZED PART.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S MY NAME IS TOBY DOING
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE
HOUSE SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
CALIFORNIA HAS STRUGGLED FOR
MANY YEARS TO SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES TO
PARTNER TO MEET THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF OFTEN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
THIS BILL REALLY MOVES IN THE
DIRECTION OF CREATING SOME
INCENTIVE FUNDS TO SUPPORT
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE NECESSARY.
WE'VE SEEN HAVE RENEWED
WILLINGNESS ON THE PART OF
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH AGENCIES TO GET TOGETHER.
BUT QUITE OFTEN THEIR BARRIERS
THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT FO THEM
TO PARTNER.
THE BILL DOES A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT THAT THAT THE EFFORT FOR
WHICH THE COMMISSION VERY
SUPPORTIVE ONE IT DOES MAKE SURE
THAT HALF OF THE FUNDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR WHAT WE CALL OUR
TRIAGE PROGRAM MUST BE DEDICATED
TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT IT DOES
IS IT OPENS UP THAT PROGRAM IN
WAYS THAT ALLOWS THESE THESE
DOLLARS TO BE USED IN WAYS THAT
CAN BE INTEGRATED AND TAILORED
AROUND THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
INDEPENDENT INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN.
AND WE HOPE BEGINS TO ALSO HELP
COUNTIES AND SCHOOLS RECOGNIZE
WAYS WHICH THEY CAN ALSO SUPPORT
FAMILIES WHO ALSO OFTEN A
STRUGGLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS.
THE BILL IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
PUTS SERVICES WHERE CHILDREN ARE
IN THE SCHOOLS AND BUILD THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS BILL WHERE THE
SPONSOR THE BILL MAY ASK YOU
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ERICA HOFFMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE ON THIS
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO GET THESE
PROGRAMS INTO SCHOOLS.
THAT'S WHERE THE BRIGHT WE'VE
HAD UP ISSUE WITH SOME COUNTIES
IN GETTING FUNDING FOR THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THIS BILL
TREMENDOUSLY HELP THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ON ANOTHER AND
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
I HAD THE RESPONSE ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARD EXTENT IN
SUPPORT.
JACOB KENYON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
FAVOR HOPE AGENCIES WE ARE
LISTED ON THE ANALYSIS AS
OPPOSED MUST AMENDED BUT AFTER
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE --
AND THE COMMITTEE WE ARE POOR
AND WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION TO CREATE A
COLLABORATIVE CRACK HOUSES THAT
INCLUDES CBO'S.
MANY OF ONE REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO ENABLE A WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LINE TO TELL THE
FAMILY SERVICES ALSO
REPRESENTING CASA PACIFICA
CENTER FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
PUBLIC FAMILY SERVICES SENECA
FAMILY OF AGENCIES HALFWAY
SYCAMORES CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND LINCOLN WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR WORKING
WITH US TO MAKE SOME AMENDS ARE
MOVING FROM AN OPPOSITION TO A
SUPPORT POSITION.
STEVEN MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BERMAN DATING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ON PAPER WERE STILL A
PENDING POSITION BUT THE
AUTHORED STAFF HAS WORKED
CLOSELY WITH US AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHICH WE APPRECIATE.
WILL BE MOVING TO SUPPORT AT THE
NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION --
I SEE NO OPPOSITION.
LAURIE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OTHERS MAKE A COMMENT --
CENTER THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH --
THE COMMITTEE STAFF --
TO MAKE THIS WORK.
AND I APPRECIATE OR PROVIDING
FUNDING A VERY IMPORTANT --
ONE THING MAYBE WE CAN TALK
ABOUT MAYBE NEXT YEAR IS --
REALLY THE AT THE SCHOOL SITE
LEVEL THAT'S ONE OF MY CONCERNS
AT THE SCHOOL SITE HOMES ME --
ONE COMES IN THE CLASSROOM HOW
TO WE HOW DOES THE SCHOOL ONE OF
THOSE SCHOOL SITE PROTOCOLS FOR
WHEN THEY DO --
POTENTIAL IDENTIFY STUDENTS
POTENTIALLY NEEDING SERVICES SO
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT NEXT YEAR
BUT THIS IS GOOD BECAUSE THIS
HELPS BUILD THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
SO THANK YOU.
OVER THAT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
MANY COMMITTEE MEMBER SEEING --
NINE WE DON'T YET HAVE A QUORUM
SO I'LL WAIT FOR A VERY MUCH
MEMBERS BEFORE WE THAT.
TAKE A MOTION WITH THAT --
WILL MOVE TO SENATOR WHEN WHICH
IS -- FILE
ON NUMBER.
SIX S. B. EIGHT NINE FIVE FIVE
NUMBER [inaudible]
SIX SHARE I'M.
I'M WAITING FOR ASSEMBLYMAN TARA
AND QUICKSILVER WHO IS ON THEIR
WAY TO PRESENT WITH ME CAN WE
WAY FOR A FEW MINUTES SIR.
A GAS THANK YOU --
YEAH OKAY --
COULD CALL.
YOU YOU IDIOT KALRA AND BATES
OKAY NO NO KALRA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KARLIN AND SQUAWK SOBRE VOTE AND
QUIRK SILVA OKAY I THEY BOTH
TEXT ME THEY'RE HEADING THIS WAY
SO OF YOU GIVE THEM A COUPLE MEN
THEY ALWAYS SAY THAT.
NON LOOK AT I UNDERSTAND --
THANK YOU SO OF SENATOR DODD --
IS SENATE DAUGHTER DE LEóN
[inaudible]
OR ALLEN.
MAYBE WE COULD CALL THEIR
OFFICES.
WHAT I COULD DO QUIRK SILVA IS
HERE I CAN START WITH HER?
AND THEN CAR WILL BE HERE IN A
FEW MINUTES.
OKAY SENATOR WHEN YOU MAY I
PROCEED.
THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'M HONORED
TO PRESENT S. B..
EIGHT NINE FIVE S. B. EIGHT NINE
FIVE X. THOU THERE'S THE
CALIFORNIA FIRST MODEL
CURRICULUM ON THE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN REFUGEE EXPERIENCE AND
THE COME ODEON GENOCIDE.
S. B. EIGHT NINE FIVE EXPAND
UPON THE CURRENT CURRICULUM ON
THE VIETNAM WAR ERA BY
INCORPORATING THE VOICES OF
THOSE WHO LIVED DURING THIS TIME.
INCLUDE THE TESTIMONIES OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLIC OF
VIETNAM ARMED FORCES AND THE
VIETNAMESE BOAT PEOPLE.
S. B. EIGHT NINE FIVE ALSO TELL
THE STORIES OF MILLIONS OF
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE VICTIMS OF
THE KUMAR.
BUT AS YOU.
WE JEAN.
AS TIME CONTINUES TO PASS IN THE
FIRST HAND ACCOUNTS OF
INDIVIDUAL WHO LIVED DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR AND THE COP COMMODE
AND GENOCIDE.
ARE LOST TO TIME IT HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAKE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO
PRESERVE THEIR STORIES FOR THE
EDUCATION BENEFIT OF OUR
CHILDREN.
SINCE I INTRODUCED THIS BILL S.
B. NINE FIVE HAS GARNERED
WIDESPREAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING.
FROM VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS AS
WELL AND ALSO EDUCATION
ASSOCIATIONS.
OVER THE COURSE OF TWO SENATE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WERE PRESENT
IN SUPPORT AND MORE THAN.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS HAVE SUBMITTED
SIGNED PETITIONS MANY OF WHOM
ALL REFUGEES THEMSELF THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
OUR STUDENTS USER TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE COMPLETE HISTORY OF THE
VIETNAM WAR ERA.
AND THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE ONE
THAT WOULD HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
HOW HOURS HISTORY SHAPES OUR WAR
VIEW.
I'M GRATEFUL TO ALSO HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS KARA AND QUICK
SERVER SOBRE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AS CO AUTHOR AND FOR JOINING ME
TODAY IN PRESENTING S. B..
EIGHT NINE FIVE THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE BY CAN YOU MY
TIME OVER. TO SEVEN NUMBER
PACIFIC.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I'M
PLEASED HERE TO WORK A IN A VERY
CLOSE UP SUPPORT OF THIS BILL A
SOME OF YOU MAY NOT KNOW BUT MY
DISTRICT IS DIRECTLY ADJACENT.
TO SENATOR NO WINS DISTRICT AND
WITH THAT WE HAVE A GROWING
NUMBER OF VIETNAMESE NOT ONLY
STUDENTS BUT FAMILIES IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND AS WE HAVE MORE AND MORE A
CULTURALLY DIVERSE OF PEOPLE IN
OUR DISTRICT FROM KOREAN
AMERICAN TO VIETNAMESE TO LATINO
WE KNOW UNDERSTANDING THEIR
HISTORIES IN THEIR BACKGROUNDS
AND WHAT THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH
IN ORDER TO COME TO OUR COUNTRY
IS.
ALRIGHT NOW --
EVEN MORE ESSENTIAL AND AS THIS
pDELIBERATE AND INTENTIONAL WE
KNOW THAT THAT WILL BREAK DOWN
SOME OF THE STEREOTYPES THAT WE
SEE WHEN PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND
EACH OTHER'S.
HISTORY SO WITH THAT I AM PROUD
TO BE A SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL
AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT
IT AS WELL.
IF YOU MISTER.
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD
TO CO PRESENT SP.
EIGHT NINETY FIVE WITH SENATOR
IRWIN AND SERVERS OF QUICKSILVER.
THAT REQUIRES SUCH INSTRUCTION
QUALITY COMMISSION TO TOPICS THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE AND THE CONSORTIUM
GENOCIDE. FOR OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN THOUSAND BEATINGS
AMERICANS RESIDING IN SAN JOSE
MAKING THE CITY THE HOME OF THE
LARGEST COMMUNITY IF IT MEANS
AMERICANS.
OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM.
IN MY CAPACITY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE AND COMMUNITY
MEMBER OF SAN JOSE I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WITNESS THE SOLIDARITY
STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE OF THE
VIETNAMESE PEOPLE AND CULTURE.
THE VIETNAM WAR TORE APART A
COUNTRY WHOSE PEOPLE WERE LEFT
FLEEING FROM POLITICAL
PERSECUTION.
THOSE REFUGEES OF SINCE RECREATE
THEIR LIVES IN AMERICA
SUCCEEDING IN BUSINESS AND
EDUCATION ABOUT PIPELINES. FOR
FUTURE AMERICANS.
THE CAMARO ROUGE AS ONE OF THE
DEADLIEST PERIODS IN HISTORY
CURRENTLY GLOSSED OVER IN
TEXTBOOKS.
LED BY POL POT THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE WIPED OUT ANY
INDIVIDUAL DEEMED A POLITICAL
OPPONENT TEMPLES WERE BURNED
BOOKS WERE OUTLAWED AND ABOUT
ONE QUARTER OF THE COUNTRY'S
POPULATION WAS MURDERED.
STILL THE PEOPLE PERSISTENT
FOUND THEIR WAY TO AMERICAN
SHORES FOR A BETTER LIFE AND OP
AND EVEN CHILDREN.
I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT LEGISLATION
THAT INCREASES THE AWARENESS OF
AND APPRECIATION FOR A REFUGEE
AND IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS.
LET US EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN
ABOUT THE REALITIES AND TRAUMA
PAST AND PRESENT ABOUT IT MUSIC
TO BECOME MILLION AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES.
I THERE'S NO BETTER WAY TO
COMBAT THOSE HISTORICAL
ATROCITIES AND STRUGGLES AND
OVERCOME THEM AND EDUCATION
UNDERSTANDING AND COMPASSION I
THINK WE NEED.
MORE OF ALL OF THOSE THESE DAYS
SPEC WE ASK ABOUT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ISABEL GARCIA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SING NOT
ANY OPPOSITION --
SENIOR OPPOSITION WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AS TO EYES
WIDE BETWEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
AS ONE THANK YOU FOR THE BILL --
PERSON I REPRESENT --
ACTUALLY THAT YOU ARE MY SENATOR
CENTER WHEN [inaudible]
BUT I I CLOSER TO MY HOME IS --
THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE GLORIA SO I'M GLAD THAT
THEY'RE INCLUDING THIS BILL IN
MY OWN EXPERIENCE MY PARENTS
ACTUALLY.
TALKED IN THE GARDEN GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR A
LONG TIME.
SO UNFAMILIAR WITH THE CAMERA AT
THE VIETNAMESE EXPERIENCE
THROUGH THEM BUT ALSO I TAUGHT
THERE -- ESL
AT NIGHT FOR MANY YEARS AND
VIETNAMESE JUST.
SO YOU KNOW I'M SOMEWHAT
FAMILIAR WITH THIS EXPERIENCE
AND THE HISTORY THERE.
AND THE TRAGEDY IN THE TRIUMPH
ONCE THEY HAVE ARRIVED IN
AMERICAN MADE IT A BETTER PLACE
SO WITH THAT I I THINK YOU
REALLY LOVE THEM TO BE A CO
AUTHOR.
AND WITH YOUR PERMISSION FOR
SURE -- AND
WITH THAT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
MANY OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
OKAY -- OKAY
WE'RE GONNA SAVAGE QUAN REYES SO
GOODNIGHT LET'S CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
O'DONNELL HERE O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY KILEY HILL HERE KALRA.
KALRA HERE MCCARTY STEINORTH
THURMOND WEBER.
WEBER HERE.
SO IT WAS OUR PREVIOUSLY MOVED
AND SECONDED [inaudible]
IF.
I WITH THAT --
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR I
AM.
YOUR TIME --
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
WE REALLY APPRECIATE MEN I GET
TO REPRESENT THE LARGEST ENEMIES
RESIDENT OUTSIDE VIETNAM AND
RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO ME IS THE
LARGEST RESIDENT OF THE
COMMODITY COMMUNITY OUTSIDE
CAMBODIA.
AND SO IT'S A GREAT BILL I THINK
IT'S YOU KNOW --
WE ALSO HAVE A A JOINT AUTHOR
WITH SUN SENATOR --
RICARDO LARA AS WELL AND SO THIS
IS A GREAT MATCH AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SPORT AND THANK
YOU -- FOR
PLEASE GIVE MY THANKS APPRECIATE
YOUR PARENTS BECAUSE THEY KNOW
SPECIALLY PARTICULAR GARDEN
GROVE WHERE I GREW UP WENT TO
GARGLE HIGH SCHOOL.
ON LOTS OF VIMY SAMARITANS A LOT
OF ENEMIES REFUGEES WHO IN
SEVENTY FIVE AFTER SEVEN FIVE
WAS REALLY WORKING HARD TO TRY
TO LEARN AND UNDERSTAND THIS
GREAT NATION AND WHAT.
SHE'S ABLE TO GIVE TO US AND SO
WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND I
DON'T.
I'M GOING. TO THANK YOU AND MY
RIGHT THERE --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL.
I AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE FOR THE LIST FOR
VOTES OF THOSE OUT NEXT --
I DON'T KNOW WHO.
IT'S WAS CENTER DALY DOES NOT
WEARING A TIE AS HE IS HE GOING
TO COME BEFORE US WITHOUT A TIE
I IS READY.
THIS IS UNIQUE THAT WE'RE GOING
THAT YOU PRESENT.
YOUR DAILY ON WITHOUT A TIE ON
YOU'VE GOT THE GAVIN NEWSOM LOOK
GOING HERE.
YOU'RE GOING TO IS THIS IS OUR
FILE ITEM NUMBER. TO SP TWO TWO
SEVEN AS ARE THROUGH TWO SEVEN
THANK YOU MUCH --
MISTER CHAIR HAVE MISTER VICE
CHAIR --
KILEY AND MISSILE WEBER FROM SAN
DIEGO SWELLED MISTER CALDERON
FOOT ALTITUDE TO PRESENT US IN
THE BUILT A TWO TWO SEVEN A AS
YOU KNOW --
MISS ADJOURNMENTS VICE CHAIR
LAST YEAR ALL WASHINGTON RUSH TO
PASS.
HE GROSSLY IRRESPONSIBLE TAX
PLAN TO GIVE THE WEALTHIEST
AMERICANS AND CORPORATIONS A
MORE THAN ONE TRILLION DOLLAR
TAX CUT.
AT OUR EXPENSE.
THIS REPUBLICAN TAX SCANDAL
LIBERALLY TARGETS AMERICANS IN
BLUE STATES QUITE FRANKLY.
THOSE STATES HAVE VOTED
OVERWHELMINGLY AGAINST A DONALD
TRUMP IN THE COULD CAUSE
CALIFORNIANS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN FACT THE AVERAGE CAL FOR
TAXPAYER NAY SAY AVERAGE TAX FOR
CLASS THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN --
WHAT IT WOULD FOR TRUMP OR YOU
SANDERS OR DELUDE CLINTON?
THE AVERAGE TAX DEDUCTION USING
THIS EXEMPTION SALT STATE AND
LOCAL TAX IS ROUGHLY AT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
A YEAR.
NOW THAT DEDUCTION HAS BEEN
CAPPED TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
MEANING ALMOST THREE MILLION
SPECIFICALLY. THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WILL LOSE OUT ON
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AVAILABLE
DEDUCTIONS EACH YEAR ON THEIR
FEDERAL TAXES.
SENATE BILL TWO TWO SEVEN IS
DESIGNED TO ENSURE CALTRANS
WOULD HAVE TO FOOT THE BILL. FOR
THIS RIDICULOUS TAX GIVEAWAY BY
GIVING THEM A CHARVEL OUTLET
THAT WILL HELP THEM WHILE
HELPING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
SO BILL TO DO SOME WOULD ALSO
CREATE A FUND THAT TAXPAYERS CAN
CREEP SHOOT CAN CONTRIBUTE TO WE
SHOULD GIVE THEM AN 85% TAX
CREDIT ON EVERY DOLLAR THEY
COULD YOU IT.
IT'S VERY SO MUCH MY MEASURE
DEALING WITH CAL GRANTS WHICH I
BELIEVE ONE OF YOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS NOW WANTS TO ACTUALLY
EXTEND THAT TELL A CAL GRANT
EXTENSION WITH AT FIFTY CENTS ON
THE DOLLAR.
WHICH IS A LOT OF CALIFORNIA.
THEN RELYING ON LONG STANDING
FEDERAL CHERNOBYL CONTRIBUTION
RULE THE TAXPAYER CAN DEDUCT.
THE AMOUNT LISTED ON THEIR
CERTIFICATION FROM THE FEDERAL
TAXES EXACTLY AS IT WOULD UNDER
STATE AND LOCAL TAX DEDUCTION.
THAT THE REPUBLICANS CAPPED IN
WASHINGTON DC.
WE ALSO HAVE A COMPANION
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT OF ITS
CHARMS VICE CHAIR OF SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
TWENTY THREE WHICH PROTECTS ALL
OF OUR EDUCATION FUNDING
FORMULAS MAKING SURE WE MEET ALL
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS BEFORE
ADMINISTERING THIS CREDIT.
ALL IT WOULD BE AT THE STATE AND
ITS TAXPAYERS IF WE OFFERED A
MENU OF CHERNOBYL OPTIONS SO
THEY CAN CHOOSE HOW THEY WANT TO
PUT THEIR CHORTLE GIVING TO WORK.
TAKEN TOGETHER THIS MEASURE
ALONG WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S
BARRACKS A MEASURE.
TWO TWO SEVEN THE VAST MAJORITY
I THINK OF EVERY MEMBER I SHOULD
VOTE FOR FUN SET FOR YOU THE
ILLUSTRIOUS VICE CHAIR OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE --
WHAT'S AB --
TWO TWO SEVEN ALONG WITH THAT
MOVE IS ANOTHER MEASURE COMING
WE'LL OFFER CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
THAT MENU OF OPTIONS HELPING
THEM.
GIVE TO THE CAUSE OF THEIR
CHOICE WITH SHARP I WANT TO
BEGIN BY OFFER TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT. TO MAKE --
TWO TWO SEVEN SHOULD SAY SENATE
BILL TWO TWO SEVEN CONTINGENT.
ON THE VOTERS APPROVAL OF SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL --
AMENDMENT NUMBER TWENTY THREE
THAT WAY WE CAN HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONALLY BE A GUARANTEE
THAT WE PROTECT OUR FUNDING
FORMULAS AND HOLD.
UP PROP NINETY EIGHT ARE
HARMLESS BY DOING SO WE LOVE THE
TAXPAYERS OF CALIFORNIA TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE BETTERMENT OF
OUR STATE.
HOPING CALIFORNIA WHILE THEY
HELP THEMSELVES THIS MEASURE
WOULD PROTECT OVER THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS AND CAN
ONLY ONLY LET ME UNDERSCORE ONLY
BENEFIT OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THEREFORE I RECENTLY ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN A POLL
OPPOSED TO SPT TWENTY SEVEN AS
WELL AS THE COMPANION AS HE
TWENTY THREE FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS HIM WHILE WE CERTAINLY
DON'T SUPPORT THE RECENT CHANGES
TO THE FEDERAL SALT TAXES --
WE UNFORTUNATELY DO NOT SUPPORT
THESE MEASURES MOVING FORWARD AS
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON PROP
NINETY EIGHT FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO SAY
NOW THAT THE THIS IS GONNA BE
CONJOINED WITH THEIR CA.
TWENTY SO HOW WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT BUT S. B. TWO TWENTY SEVEN
DOES NOT RECONCILE THE TAX YEAR
BASIS WOULD PROP NINETY EIGHT
FISCAL YEAR BASIS.
IT ALSO FEELS TO INCLUDE THE
BASELINE SUPPLEMENT --
SUB ACCOUNT INTO THE ACTUAL
MAINTENANCE FACTOR ITSELF IT
ALSO DOESN'T PROVIDE --
FOR WHAT HAPPENS IN THE EVENT
THAT THE IRS SAYS THAT --
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO ACCEPTANCE
OUT WHAT HAPPENS TO THE FUNDS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN PAID HOW
ARE THEY GOING TO BE REALLOCATED
HOW'S THAT GOING TO IMPACT PROP
NINETY IN EDUCATIONAL FUNDING.
ADDITIONALLY IT DOESN'T
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
SCHOOLS RIGHT TO SUPPLEMENTAL
SUB ACCOUNT FUNDS SO WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS COULD HINDER
MANY OF THE PROTECTIONS THAT
WERE ESTABLISHED IN PROP NINETY
IN FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
POSTED THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON THEIR OPPOSITION OVER
YOU BEHIND THE THE THE REAL HERE
OB I JUST WANTED YOU AYE I DO
ONE OF THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
POINTING OUT THAT CALIFORNIANS
BY AND LARGE GOING TO TAX
INCREASE.
WITH WHAT SOME CALLED A TAX CUT.
RICE THAT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE IN
FACT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
HEADLINES WEATHER HEADLINES THE
FRONT PAGE LA TIMES TODAY --
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE INSIDE
WASHINGTON THAT ARE VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE RAPID DEBT.
THEY THEY THEY DEBT THAT IS
GOING RAPIDLY AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BECAUSE OF THIS TAX CUT
FOR SOME THE TAX INCREASE FOR
OTHERS.
SO I THINK THE WHOLE PLAN.
YOU KNOW NEEDS TO BE REBOOTED --
BUT I KNOW THAT YOU WHAT YOU
DOING HERE TODAY'S YOU WANT
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT I HEAR
PEOPLE SAY LOOK GDP IS A 3% WERE
HEADED.
FOR WHY WOULD SAY WOULD YOU NEED
HE'S NOT A 3% ARE NOT A 4% IF
YOU'RE GOING INTO DEBT TO DO
THAT THAT'S JUST A CREDIT CARD.
SO AWASH IN A SCENE REALLY NEEDS
TO GET OUR FISCAL HOUSE IN ORDER.
REALLY NEEDS TO DO THAT AND
QUITE FRAIL DON'T TAKE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUDGET LISTEN I
VOTED FOR IT SUPPORTED BUT I
WISH WE WOULD HAVE DONE MORE
PAYING DOWN DEBT AND OUR LAST
YOU KNOW AND I LAST GO ROUND ON
THE BUDGET.
BUT THAT'S ANOTHER CONVERSATION
THAT I'M GOING TO TRY AND HAVE
AGAIN NEXT YEAR --
BUT WITH THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND AGAIN --
I THINK YOU'RE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU KILEY THINKING RIGHT NOW.
OKAY I IS BEEN MOVED AND WE HAVE
A SECOND HOMES A CAR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WITHOUT IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
O'DONNELL.
AYE AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA.
KALRA I. MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND AND WEBER.
WEBER AYE [inaudible]
PEOPLE.
WE GOT THROUGH THEN THE ON TO
BILLS ON COLLIER THREE VOTES
WITNESSES CHAIRMAN IS A VICE
CHAIR MISS WEBER DOZENS CALATHEA
MUCH -- I
WITH THAT WILL MOVE ON TO SENATE
WE NEED SENATOR DIED.
AND WE NEED SENATOR ALAN
.
WE DO HAVE TWO BILLS THAT WE
NEED A MOTION ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SP TEN NINETEEN HAS
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATE.
HOLMAN ON THE MOTION IS
[inaudible] TO PASS.
S. A MAN DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY STEINORTH
THURMOND WEBER.
WEBER AYE FOR FOOD TO THE BILL'S
OUT FOR VOTES BY CENTER BILLS
OUT.
AND NOW WE NEED A MOTION ON UP
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE IT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE HONEST
SENATOR FULLER.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED AND SECONDED --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
KING.
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I. MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
WEBER WEBER AYE.
RULES OUT FOR VOTES.
OR NOW AWAY AWAITING --
SENATORS DIED IN ALLEN
[inaudible]
WITHOUT
.
ALRIGHT THIS IS --
SP -- EIGHT
THIRTY BY SENATOR --
DOG BUT WE PRESENTED BY OUR OWN
CHAIR MISTER O'DONNELL MISTER
O'DONNELL YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SITE TODAY A
PRESENT A S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ARE
BY SENATOR DODD.
THIS BILL REQUIRES NSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION TO DEVELOP.
AND THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
TO ADOPT REJECT OR MODIFY A
MODEL CURRICULUM.
IN ME IN IN MEDIA LITERACY --
S. B. THIRTY FIVE EXPERIENCE NO
VOTE NO NO VOTES LAST YEAR IN
THIS COMMITTEE S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY IS THE SAME BILL WITH
DATES OF IMPLEMENTATION AMENDED
UPON REQUEST OF THE CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
A RECENT STANFORD STUDY FOUND
THAT 82% OF MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTS STRUGGLE TO DISTINGUISH
ADVERTISEMENTS FROM NEWS STORIES.
AND ALSO FOUND SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES WITH THE CIVIC CIVIC
ONLINE REASONING OF HIGH SCHOOL.
AND COLLEGE STUDENTS.
WELL WE HAVE CRITICAL THINKING
REQUIREMENTS IN OUR CURRICULUM
THEY HAVEN'T KEPT UP WITH THE
DIGITAL AGE.
BY GIVING STUDENTS THE PROPER
TOOLS TO ANALYZE THE MEDIA THEY
CONSUME WE CAN EMPOWER AND MAKE
THEM AND MET A HELP THEM MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS.
I WITH THAT I TURNED OVER TO MY
WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL CANO
KAISER ON HALF OF COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CHAIRMAN --
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IS
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OUTLINED --
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO TEACH OUR
KIDS TO BE GOOD CITIZENS IN THE
REAL WORLD.
WE MUST STRIVE TO TEACH THEM TO
BE GOOD ETHICAL STE DIGITAL
CITIZENS AS WELL.
ON IN THE PAST TWO YEARS CARMEN
SENSE BECAUSE ACTION HAS MET
WITH UNSPOKEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SEVERAL TIMES. TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILL ALIGNS WITH
THEIR CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT
TIMELINE IN REQUIREMENTS.
THESE ARE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
AND COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IS
GRATEFUL TO THE OTHER --
ON ENSURE THAT THE BILL AGAIN
MEETS THE DEPARTMENT'S
GUIDELINES AND WE URGE YOU I
THINK YOU --
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS JEFF FROST RIBS IN THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION ARM.
YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS AT THE CHANGES
IN TECHNOLOGY --
YOU KNOW WE STARTED IN THE
EDUCATION TECHNOLOGY WORLD WITH
GETTING KIDS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
COMPUTERS WERE AND HOW TO TURN
THEM ON AND NOW THEY DO THAT FOR
US -- THE
WORLD OF MEDIA AND LITERACY AND
THE POLITICS OF THE WORLD HAVE
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY JUST IN THE
LAST.
FEW YEARS THERE IS NO AREA OF
OUR CURRICULUM THAT DEALS WITH
THAT ISSUE --
WE THINK THAT THIS BILL WAS A
LONG STEP --
TO SOLVING THAT PROBLEM AND
WORRIED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST KAREN LAYING ON
BEHALF OF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE PARTICULARLY AS
IT RELATES TO THE CRITICAL.
THINKING ASPECT OF IT THANK YOU.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
IS ABOUT GARCIA BE HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
STEAMER SALAS THE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MEDIA BORN AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND I MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH
[inaudible]
THEY'RE MEANT.
WEBER.
WEBER AYE [inaudible] THREE
VOTES.
I THAT IS THREE VOTES THE BILL'S
ON CALL
[inaudible]
IF.
MISTER CHAIR --
I'D LIKE TO PRESENT SB --
SEVEN TWENTY IT'S THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION BILL BY
MR ON IT WAS ON CONSENTED TO IT.
AND IT WAS PULLED OFF.
AGAIN THAT'S SP SEVEN TWENTY I
DO NOT KNOW THE FILE ITEM.
IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN NUMBER THREE I'M SORRY
FILE MEMBERS NUMBER [inaudible]
THREE UFC.
WE THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE.
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL.
S. B. SEVEN TWENTY INCORPORATES
THE EXISTING ENVIRONMENTAL
PRINCIPLES AND CONCEPTS INTO
FUTURE CORE CURRICULUM UPDATES.
DIRECTS THE SUIT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO WRITE LEADERSHIP
TO INCREASE ENVIRONMENTAL
LITERACY IN SCHOOLS AND
ENCOURAGES IN GOVERNING BOARD TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PROMOTE.
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE CALIFORNIA
PASSED THE FIRST ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION LAW IN THE UNITED
STATES BY CREATING A SET OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PRINCIPLES AND
CONCEPTS WITH THE GOAL OF
FOSTERING COMPREHENSIVE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.
AMONG STUDENTS.
OUR STUDENT POPULATION.
THE NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS WHICH HAVE RECENTLY
BEEN ADOPTED BY THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION INCORPORATED THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRINCIPLES.
HOWEVER UNDER CURRENT LAW THESE
PRINCIPLES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
BE INTEGRATED INTO FUTURE
CONTENT STANDARDS AND CURRICULUM.
BY INTEGRATING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PRINCIPLES INTO THE CONTENT
STANDARDS AND CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS IN THE IN ENGLISH IN
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS OF
SCIENCE HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
AND HEALTH AND MATH.
WE WILL FOSTER AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY LITERATE
POPULATION AND ENSURE THAT
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A FIRM
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
ENVIRONMENTAL CHOICES HAVE
SHAPED OUR PASS.
AND WILL SHAPE OUR FUTURE.
ADDITIONALLY SB SEVEN TWENTY
ENCOURAGES SCHOOL DISTRICT
GOVERNING BOARDS.
A PLACE ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY ELEMENTS
INTO THE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY [inaudible]
PLANS.
FINALLY THE BILL DIRECTS THE FBI
TO USE AVAILABLE RESOURCES TO
FURTHER THE GOALS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY
ENCOURAGES COOPERATION.
BETWEEN EDUCATION ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENCIES WHEN UPDATING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRINCIPLES IN THE
FUTURE.
INTEGRATING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PRINCIPLES HONEST INTO THE
STATEWIDE CURRICULUM REINFORCES
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
ENVIRONMENTALLY LITERATE.
POPULATION ENSURES OUR STUDENTS
CAN DEAL WITH FUTURE
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS ARIEL WHAT'S IN --
AND TED'S TEN STRANDS AREA
WHAT'S IN IT HAD STRAIGHTENED
STRANDS [inaudible]
SORRY.
I'M ARE ELLISON WITH TEN STRANDS
WE LEAD AND MANAGE THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
LITERACY INITIATIVE.
OUR WORK FOCUSES ON ESTABLISHING
A SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IS INFORMED BY STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOILET SINCE
BLUEPRINT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
LITERACY.
S. B. SEVEN TWENTY INCLUDES
CHANGES THAT WILL DEEPEN
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH AGENCIES
COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL PRINCIPLES AND
CONCEPTS.
GIVE CLEAR DIRECTION TO THE NEW
AS HAS P. I TO FACILITATE
BRINGING ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY
TO STUDENTS.
AND ENCOURAGE LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS TO BE MORE ACTIVE AROUND
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY.
AND STRENGTHEN CALC RECYCLES
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT ABILITY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO IT
EDUCATION AND RESOURCE AGENCIES
WHENEVER YOUNG PEOPLE ARE BEING
EDUCATED ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
USING THE EP AND SEES.
AND TO FACILITATE A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS.
FOR WE BELIEVE SB SEVEN TWENTY
IS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
BUILDING A SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL LITERACY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THE BILL.
A GOOD AFTERNOON OF MISTER CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR RECALL MONSTER
DID NOT A WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND.
A I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER A
TESTIFIED IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT
WE HAVE BEEN AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR FORTY YEARS
BUILDING PARKS AND PROTECTING
LAND AT NIGHT.
THERE SAY WE PROBABLY BUILT A
PARK IN EVERYONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS OVER THAT TIME.
AND PART OF LAW --
WHAT WE DO IS ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY WHEN ME BILL PARKS AND
COMMUNITIES?
AND MOST OF OUR PARKS HAVE
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL --
BENEFITS WHETHER IT'S ARE
CAPTURING STORMWATER OR CLEANING
THE HELPING TO FILTER WATER THAT
COMES TO THE GROUND --
PROVIDES CARBON SEQUESTRATION
AND THEN AND SHADE FROM THE HEAT --
AND WE EDUCATE THE KIDS THE COME
TO THE RIBBON CUTTING SEMESTER
YOU REALLY USUALLY THE ONLY
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION THEY'RE
GONNA GET UNTIL THEIR BIOLOGY
CLASS IN TENTH GRADE.
AND THEN MAYBE WE CAN GET SOME
OF OUR MENTAL EDUCATION AND
COLLEGE IF YOU ELECT.
TO I'M I I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE HAVE --
FACING US RIGHT NOW ARE ALL
ENVIRONMENTAL --
WHERE WE GONNA GET OUR DRINKING
WATER WHERE WE GONNA HOW WE
GONNA CLEAN OUR AIR WHAT WE
GONNA DO ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
WERE COUNTING ON FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO HELP SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS?
IT SHOULD BE A PART OF THE CORE
CURRICULUM IOTHER THIS ISN'T
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR WRITTEN
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BREAKAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HILDA BASED SURFRIDER
WHILE COAST AND ON THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CLEAN CEASED
LOBBYING COALITION AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN X..
ASKED TO EXPRESS SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB.
THANK YOU MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM DOCTOR
WEBER IS THERE A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS.
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL AYE AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY NOT.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH
[inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL IS ON CALL.
MISTER CHAIR ONE MORE --
IT'S S. B. NINE THIRTY THREE I
DO NOT KNOW THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
S. B. NINE THREE THREE THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B. NINE THREE
THREE ALSO BY SENATOR ALLEN BUT
PRESENTED BY MISTER.
GREAT THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
OF FIRST I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR WORK.
AND OF COURSE THE CHAIR AS WELL --
SP.
NINE THIRTY THREE ESTABLISHES
THE ARTS FOR EVERY STUDENT ACT
WHICH IS INTENDED TO CLOSE THE
GAP AND ACCESS TO VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS EDUCATION FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THE ACT WHICH IS FUNDED IN THE
BUDGET CREATES AN INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SCHOOLS TO
CREATE NEW PROGRAMS AND BUILD
UPON EXISTING PROGRAMS. O
EXPAND ARTS EDUCATION ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES A STUDENTS
IN GRADES SKATE THROUGH TWELVE
WRIST YOU ARTS EDUCATION THAT
INCLUDES ELEMENTS OF DANCE.
MUSIC VISUAL ARTS AND THEATRE.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS DATA PROJECT WITH ONLY 39%
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WERE
ENROLLED IN AN ARTS COURSE.
DURING THE PAST SCHOOL YEAR.
ARTS EDUCATION HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
IMPROVE CRITICAL THINKING AND
PROBLEM SOLVING SKILLS.
FACILITATE CROSS CULTURAL
UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
SEVERAL STUDIES HAVE DETERMINED
THAT ARTS EDUCATION HELPS BOOST
LITERACY ADVANCED MATH
ACHIEVEMENT AND INCREASES
CAPACITY FOR LEADERSHIP.
S. B. NINE THIRTY THREE PROVIDES
A ONE TIME INVESTMENT TO CREATE
NEW PROGRAMS FOR SCHOOLS WITH
LIMITED ARTS RESOURCES AND
PROVIDING FUNDING FOR EXISTING
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO EXPAND ARTS
EDUCATION ACCESS.
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE BILL SEEKS TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO UNDERSERVED UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS BY PROVIDING
RESOURCES FOR INNOVATIVE AND
INTEGRATED MULTI TO DISCIPLINARY
PROGRAMS.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE AT MR ALLEN
IS THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON ARTS.
AND HE'S PASSIONATE ABOUT
PROVIDING ARTS EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO KIDS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
AND HE BELIEVES THAT THIS BILL
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO EXPAND ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. TO ARTS EDUCATION.
WITH ME I TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
KATHY LYNCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR ARTS
EDUCATION A MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU I'M COME MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
ALLEN AND THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY.
COMMITTEE FOR THE BENEFICIAL.
EDUCATION AND IT WAS POINTED OUT
WE ARE VERY PLEASED THAT THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET --
SIGNED.
A DOES INCLUDE FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS --
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS EDUCATION IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET --
S. B. NINE THIRTY THREE IS THE
VISION FOR THAT FUNDING ON THIS
GIVE SCHOOL THE NEED TO JUMP
START IN VISUAL PERFORMING ARTS
THAT IS NEEDED.
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION CODE
DOES REQUIRE THAT ALL K. TWELVE
STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE VISUAL ON
PERFORMING ARTS INSTRUCTION
HOWEVER YET THAT THE VISUAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS DATA PROJECT
CONCLUDES ABOUT ONLY 39%.
OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
PARTICIPATE ME ARE OUR EMERALD
PARTS OF THE STATE IN SOME OF
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WITH ONE IN TEN JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA CONNECTED TO THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY AND TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LEAVE ANY OF OUR
STUDENTS BEHIND.
WHERE YOU LIVE SHOULD NOT
DICTATE WHETHER YOU HAVE ACCESS
TO THE ARTS AND WE HOPE TO MAKE
INROADS WITH THIS FUNDING?
AS WELL AS REACH OUT TO OUR
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS IN
GREATER NUMBERS AS THE ARTS CAN
BE THERAPEUTIC AS WELL AS
MAGICAL ON THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
WE THANK THE COMMITTEE ON
THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN GREAT
BIPARTISAN LEADERSHIP IN THIS
COMMITTEE FOR BUSH ON PERFORMING
ARTS AND WE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND FOR THE COMMITTEE STAFFS
WORK IN AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOUR OPINIONS ON NATIONAL THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
IN SUPPORT.
BACKGROUND SO CHAU YOUR RATES
WILL BE HAVE THE CITY COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF MY
APOLOGIES FOR NOT.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THE
WONDERFUL COMPANY IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR THE
GIFTED IN SUPPORT.
NICK LEON BALFE THEY SELL YOUR
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
THINK YOU'RE MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AYE WELL I MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT --
YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY --
AYE I'M A BELIEVER IN THE POWER
OF OF ARTS EDUCATION AND I AND I
THINK THERE SHOULD BE MORE ABOUT
AYE WELL.
HOW WORD OF CAUTION THAT THIS
SEEMS TO BE --
ANOTHER CATEGORICAL PROGRAM WILL
CREAING THAT IS SOMEWHAT AT
ODDS I WITH THE SPIRIT OF LCF
BATH AND SO I THINK WE NEED DE
THINK A LITTLE YOU KNOW MORE
BROADLY ABOUT --
IF THIS IS GOING TO BE A
PRIORITY ARTS EDUCATION WHAT'S
THE BEST WAY TO ACTUALLY PROMOTE
THAT ONE ALTERNATIVE FOR EXAMPLE
MIGHT BE GIVING.
LOCAL LAW SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS --
MORE FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS ABOUT
WHAT THEIR OFFERINGS ARE SO IF
YOU LIVE WITHIN A DISTRICT MIGHT
BE ONE SCHOOL THAT DOES A LOT
WITH ARTS EDUCATION AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT AND IF
THAT'S NOT IMPORTANT YOU CAN GO
TO ANOTHER SCHOOL SO I AM.
I VERY MUCH --
YOU KNOW I AND AS WE REVISIT
THIS --
ISSUE IN FUTURE YEARS OUT WE
SHOULD.
THINK HARD ABOUT WHAT THE RIGHT
APPROACHES --
BUT TACK WE DO HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
THERE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS UP
WITH CULTURAL THAT I'M JUST
GOING TO STIR AND OBJECT CLOSE
AT THE CLOSE A JUST JUST JUST.
JUST IN RESPONSE TO A COUPLE OF
YOUR COMMENTS A MISTER VICE
CHAIR MISTER CHAIR RIGHT NOW --
I U. S. --
YOU YOU YOU YOU OBSERVE THAT YOU
KNOW MAYBE SOME DISTRICTS DON'T
HAVE.
A DIFFERENT ART PROGRAMS AT SOME
OTHER SCHOOLS I CAN TELL YOU
THAT I'M LONG BEACH WE DO WE
HAVE A MEDIA ARTS SCHOOL --
IT'S VERY COMPUTER BASED AND
THEN WE HAVE OF THE RENAISSANCE
HIGH SCHOOL WHICH IS MORE.
THE I GUESS VISUAL ARTS SPACE SO
THERE ARE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
DEVELOPING THESE PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE STATE I DON'T THINK WE WANT
TO MANDATE.
THAT TO OCCUR FROM SACRAMENTO IS
WE DON'T KNOW THE NEEDS OF EVERY
LOCAL DISTRICT AND TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT CREATING ANOTHER CANNIBAL
CORPORAL PROGRAM I DON'T THINK
THIS DOES THAT I THINK WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIOR.
AND WHAT I FOUND --
DURING MY TIME IN SACRAMENTO IS
BETTER THAT WE INCENTIVIZE
BEHAVIOR.
THEN WE MANDATE BEHAVIORS AND
YOU GET MORE SIDE WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU INCENTIVIZE IT'S DIFFERENT
TYPES OF BEHAVIOR AND AGAIN I
THINK THE INTENT HERE IS TO
CREATE THAT CAPACITY.
AT THE DISTRICT AND SCHOOL SITE
LEVEL -- TO
TO IT TOO TO CREATE BETTER ARTS
PROGRAMS AND ALSO THAT IT THAT
IT CAPACITY IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THEN A YOU KNOW AS WE MOVE
DOWN THE TIMELINE WE CAN YOU
KNOW MAYBE LOOK AT HOW ELSE CFF
CAN TAKE CARE FOR THOSE EFFORTS
AS WELL.
I CONCURRENT THOSE COMMENTS
ACTUALLY SO AYE AYE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
I PUT ON AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH THURMOND
AND WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I FOR THE FOUR NOTES THE
BILLS OUT
.
COULD I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I MOVED AND SECONDED --
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS AS
FOLLOWS I ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
FORTINO SIX MISTER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO CONCUR --
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP EIGHT NINE
TWO BY MISTER PAN THEIR MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED --
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SP LOW FOR
MISTER ROTH MOTIONS TO PASS YOU
APPROPRIATIONS FILE AND NUMBER
TEN SP TWO OR THREE BY MISS
BATES MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN SP THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
AYE MR MONEY.
NOW THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
CONSENT --
CALENDAR OF O'DONNELL I'M WITH
O'DONNELL AYE.
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE KALRA
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
BUT CARLY MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH
THURMAN WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I
YEAH I JUST WANNA MAKE A
RETIREMENT ANNOUNCEMENT HERE.
THIS IS A BITTERSWEET MOMENT IN
THE HISTORY OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE --
THIS IS FRANCE HE REVERTS OUR
OUR SECRETARY LAST COMMITTEE
HEARING AFTER SO MANY.
SERVING --
MANY CHAIR MANY MEMBERS --
IN REALLY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA MAKING CALIFORNIA
BETTER PLACE THROUGH HER OWN
EFFORTS --
AS WE WANT TO THANK HER TODAY.
SHE HAS SERVED IN HER ROLE FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE ON AND HAS WORKED
WELL FOR NINE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
BOTH REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT I
DON'T KNOW WHO HER FAVORITE AND
WHO WERE NOT --
THAT BOTH PARTIES BOTH PARTIES
SHOULD BIPARTISAN LADY RIGHT
HERE --
FRANCIE KEEPS ALL OF US IN LINE
THAT'S FOR SURE AND ALWAYS
ENSURES THAT THE COMMITTEE'S
ACTIONS ARE RECORDED AND AN
ACTIVE AND SHE'S DONE A
WONDERFUL JOB OF THAT. TO SAY
THAT SHE WILL BE MISSED IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT BOTH
PROFESSIONALLY AND PERSONALLY I
MEAN SHE'S SHE DOES HER JOB VERY
WELL BUT ON A PERSONAL LEVEL SHE
REALLY CARES ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM AND OUTSIDE OF THIS
ROOM GREATLY.
AND WE LOVE HER FOR THAT.
FRANCIE WE WISH YOU ALL THE BEST
IN RETIREMENT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR DEDICATED AND LONG LASTING
SERVICE TO THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
WE GIVE YOU --
I BELIEVE THEIR THEIR HOW CAN WE
GIVE YOU THESE FLOWERS OKAY
THESE ARE YOURS.
DIDN'T GROW THEM BUT YOU KNOW --
THEY DID SMOKERS TO THEIR VERY
POWERFUL.
A THIS IS FOR US ISN'T FROM IT
IS FROM ALL OF US AS A TOKEN OF
OUR GRATITUDE AND OUR THANKS. TO
TO BEING YOU. TO BEING YOU GANG
AND SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND I KNOW THEY WERE JUST A
COUPLE PEOPLE THAT WANTED TO SAY
A FEW WORDS I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE STILL THERE.
OKAY THIS COME FORWARD.
YEAH.
YES --
ISABEL GARCIA LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION FRANCIE.
IT'S BEEN A PRIVILEGE AND AN
HONOR WORKING WITH YOU FOR THE
LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS --
WHEN I FIRST CAME HERE FROM THE
EAST COAST YOU WERE THE ONE OF
THE FIRST PEOPLE I MET AND YOU
WERE MY GATEWAY TO CALIFORNIA
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT A
GREAT AMBASSADOR YOU HAVE BEEN?
YOUR ENERGY YOUR YOUR YOUR WELL
YOUR STELLAR PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER FOR QUALITY PUBLIC
EDUCATION OUR STUDENTS IS JUST.
YOU CAN'T PUT WORDS TO IT BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE YEARS --
WHEN YOU WERE RUNNING MARATHONS
YOU INSPIRED ME TO DO A FIVE K.
OKAY BUT THAT WAS A BIG DEAL?
BUT LET ME JUST SAY --
AS A MEMBER OF THE THIRD HOUSE
YOU OUR ESTEEMED YOU ARE REVERED
YOU ARE SUCHAN A PHENOMENAL
AMAZING PERSON.
AND I'M GLAD WE'RE IN THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOOD ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY.
TOO BUT OWN I THINK YOU FROM OF
MY HEART FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DONE YOU I KNOW EVEN FORMER
COMMITTEE STAFF OWN MONEY SOLO
VIENNA DE DE BRANIK I'M SURE
EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY THAT MEETS YOU FALLS
IN LOVE WITH YOUR ENERGY YOUR
PUPPY THERE IS NOTHING THERE'S
NO PROBLEM TOO BIG THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO NO IT YOU YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOTHING SO THEY CAN
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING
[inaudible]
FRANCIE [inaudible]
LEYVA --
SEEKING FOR ERICA BECAUSE SHE
SAID SHE WOULD CRY --
SO.
SO FROM THE BOTH OF US.
WHO WERE PROBABLY THE ONLY TWO
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM WHO PRE DATE
YOU?
IN THIS BUILDING.
WHICH HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
YOUR AGE BUT YOUR LONGEVITY ON
THIS COMMITTEE --
THOSE OF US THAT WORK IN AND
AROUND THIS COMMITTEE UNDERSTAND.
THAT JUST LIKE AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL WHERE THE SCHOOL
SECRETARY RUNS THE SCHOOL YOU
RUN THIS PLACE --
YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE CALLS
THAT. NINE TEN IN THE MORNING
WHEN THE COMMITTEE WAS DONE AT
ELEVEN THIRTY THE NIGHT BEFORE.
ASKING WHAT WAS THE VOTE ON THIS
BILL I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
AMENDMENTS AND YOU NEVER YELL AT
US.
YOU'RE ALWAYS CALM YOU'RE ALWAYS
HAPPY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY IT'S BEEN
GREAT WORKING WITH YOU.
AND ERIC CARE AND I ARE GONNA
TAKE YOU OUT FOR DRINKS.
FRANCIE OF MICHAEL HALL SAYS OUR
WITH KERN COUNTY I JUST WANT I
THINK YOU MOSTLY PERSONALLY.
ON MY CAME HERE OVER TWENTY
YEARS AGO AND HAD NO IDEA WHERE
ANYTHING WAS.
AND FRANCIE YOU'RE THE FIRST
PERSON TO ACTUALLY SAY WELL I'M
FROM KERN COUNTY.
AND FRANCIE GROPING WASCO.
AND SHE KIND OF TOOK ME UNDER
HER WING WHEN SHE FOUND OUT.
I'D BEEN IN KERN AND SHE'S JUST.
I I CERTAINLY ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE MY TWO COLLEAGUES WHO
SPOKE BEFORE ME YOU'VE JUST BEEN
A FABULOUS PERSON.
AND A FRIEND AND BUT YOU'RE ALSO
AN INCREDIBLE PROFESSIONAL AND I
WOULD SECOND WHAT JEFF SAID YOU
RUN THIS PLACE SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL THAT
YOU'VE DONE FOR ALL OF US.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS WITH CAPITAL
ADVISORS GROUP BY MR SHARE WITH
YOUR PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO READ
A STATEMENT FROM MY COLLEAGUE
GERRY SHELTON OF FORMER CHIEF
CONSULTANT TO THIS COMMITTEE WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I COUNT MYSELF LUCKY TO BE AMONG
THE MANY CONSULTANTS CHIEFS IN
CHAIRS WHO OBSERVE THIS
COMMITTEE AND WHO HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTED OVER THE YEARS BY
FRANCIE RUPERT.
FRANCIE THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
TIME AND WORK THAT YOU'VE PUT
INTO THE BENEFIT OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
THE HOUSE AND MOST ESPECIALLY
THE SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA ALL THE BEST FOR YOUR
FUTURE JERRY.
I'M WE HAVE A LOT ON THIS BEEN
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
ESPECIALLY --
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUES IN.
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS DIVISION WANT
TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK
YOU.
YOU BEEN A GREAT PERSON TO WORK
WITH.
ESPECIALLY DURING THOSE TIMES
WHEN IT'S VERY HECTIC WHO IS
ALWAYS NICE HEARING OUR A
WELCOMING FRIENDLY VOICE ON THE
PHONE.
OR WELCOMING SMILE WHEN WE COME
INTO THE OFFICE AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK AND WISH YOU
NOTHING BUT THE VERY BEST LUCK.
FRANCE IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I WAS ACTUALLY HAD A FAX MY
OFFICE UNTIL I RECOGNIZE WE DO
ON THIS HONOR --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE FOR US TEACHERS AND
AS A YOUNG STAFFER WHO STARTED
THE VOTING ALMOST TWO DECADES
AGO.
I'M YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL TO ME VERY NURTURING --
SO VERY VERY MUCH.
I'M AND I'M ALWAYS INGRATITUDE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR AS GREAT I
THINK YOU ARE TO THOSE WHO WHO.
SHARED THEIR THEIR THOUGHTS --
AND AND ABOUT OF GREAT LADY WITH
GREAT SERVICE TO THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE STATE SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FRANCIE ALRIGHT.
EVERYBODY LOVES YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOU.
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF WORK TO CONCLUDE HERE --
THERE ARE THREE BILLS ON CALL SO
GO AHEAD AND I TAKE A VOTE ON
THOSE NOW THREE BILLS ON CALL --
THE FIRST BILL WILL TAKE UP IS --
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO IT'S SP TWO
TWO SEVEN BY MISTER DE LEóN.
S. B. TWO TWO SEVEN BY MISTER DE
LEóN.
BUT IF YOU DO THIS RIGHT NOW.
I'M SORRY AND OTHER THE MOTION
AUTONOMY THAT THE MOTION.
BETTER THEY DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE TWO TWO SEVEN OKAY HERE WE
GO [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
CARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NO THURMOND
[inaudible]
THURMOND I THE BILL IS OUT.
AGAIN I KNOW MOVED TO SB SEVEN
TWENTY BY SENATOR ALAN.
S. B. SEVEN TWENTY THE MOTION ON
SB SEVEN TWENTY IS.
DO PASS AS AMENDED SB SEVEN
TWENTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE THURMAN
[inaudible]
THURMOND I IT HELPED THE BILL'S
OUT RIGHT AND THAT WE HAVE S. B.
FIVE OR FOUR S. B.. EIGHT THIRTY
BY SENATOR DODD.
THE MOTION ON SENATOR DODD'S
BILL IS.
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS SB
[inaudible]
THIRTY IS KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE.
THE NEBULOUS OUT.
TAKES A LOT THAT --
SO YOU WILL TAKE THE ADULTS
ENTER THE MIA DURING THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FRANCINE
THANK YOU.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED